wow overwhelmed uh so I'm gonna read off
a paper because it's a lot
we are honored to be standing here today
to receive the star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame this is a testament to the
love and support of our fans our family
and our friends
who have been with us every step of the
way
thank you to everyone that has shown up
and even flown in for this moment we are
so grateful to everyone who has made
this possible from our label
to our management
to the media
and of course most importantly our fans
[Applause]
behind everything we do and we could not
have done this without you so thank you
thank you yeah
but first
Danielle my beautiful wife
I love you
so much I could not have done this
without you your support over the last
15 years
you've seen us through all of it the
beginning the middle the end and then
back again
thank you for everything
Alina Valentina
this is a pretty cool moment don't you
think yeah
well I will be honest this is cool but
you too are my brightest stars so I love
you and thank you
oh and uh
to Joe and Nick
couldn't have been here without you so
I love you
this is pretty awesome so thank you
[Applause]
hello hello
this journey has been a wild ride and we
are so grateful to have the opportunity
to share this passion for of music
for so long with the world
we've been through many ups and downs
but through it all we have remained
Brothers
and have stayed true to our passion for
music
we would like to take a moment to thank
our parents for their unwavering support
and love
they've always been our biggest
cheerleaders and I've been with us every
step of the way
to my little ones at home Daddy loves
you to the Moon and back
[Applause]
Sophie what up homie
you're my partner in crime you keep me
motivated and inspired every day I
strive to be as cool as you
and you got you got any plans after this
Kevin and Nick
I love you like brothers
honestly it's been an amazing ride and
uh
heck we'll be here in 30 more years
because this is just the beginning
[Applause]
hello hello
I'm gonna start with Mom Dad we love you
so much we would literally not be here
without you so thank you
and Franklin Jonas
we love you we're so grateful you're
here
uh to my beautiful wife
uh you are
you are the the the calm and the crazy
The Rock in the storm and I love being
married to you it is the greatest gift
and I love being a parent with you so
multi-marie I've been
I can't wait to come back here with you
in 15 years and embarrass you in front
of your friends
foreign
Phil McIntyre and our entire management
team
[Applause]
none of this happens without you
believing in us from the beginning so
thank you for everything I can't wait
for this next chapter
Monty Avery Wendy the entire Republic
team thank you for your belief in us and
making Republic records the absolute uh
most wonderful home for us uh we are so
grateful to all of you appreciate it
uh John Ryan thanks for your words
making music uh is cool but making music
with people you love and care about is
that much cooler so thank you guys
uh Greg Jack John day one uh you became
family and to see you you here with us
today is really meaningful to all of us
uh
Kevin Joe
um I don't want to get emotional we can
do that later but I love you guys very
much um
I'm glad that that that day we decided
not to do this anymore that we changed
our minds together
[Applause]
um and to all the shoulders that we've
been lucky enough to ride on in our work
and our personal relationships some of
you that are here today thank you you're
all Giants in your own way and we are so
grateful to have your support and your
love and uh care about all of you very
much
uh and finally to our amazing fans
as you that are here today and watching
uh online
you are you are family and we we love
you and we're so thankful for your
support
you know it's it's nice to to reflect on
this nearly 20-year journey and to
commemorate it here today
um
but we're looking towards the future and
what's coming next so with that
with that I think that we should make a
quick announcement
uh we are excited to announce today
that our new album
the album will be coming out May 5th
and we can't wait to see you on tour
later this year thank you all so much
[Applause]